[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in sallys es
ist wieder soweit samira hat geburtstag
und wird elf jahre alt und dieses jahr
hat sie sich nur moderne torte gewünscht
keine kindliche keine mädchen torte und
sie fährt er so gern inlineskates und
das auch richtig gut mittlerweile fährt
sie auch gerne mal schlittschuh gerade
jetzt zur winterzeit und deswegen habe
ich mir gedacht mache ich hier eine
moderne torte mit einem schlittschuh
drauf schreibt da freut sie sich sehr
darüber wir haben uns auch so ein paar
tropfen in den angeschaut aber nichts
passendes gefunden und sie meint es
hawass mit eis und mit effekten und was
modernes gefällt ihr gut also gibt es
hier diese torte ich habe das ganze an
zwei tagen jetzt zubereitet ihr könnt
euch nämlich da auch wie immer die
torten backzeit so ein bisschen ein teil
am ersten tag die böden backen und auch
gern die frucht einen daten schon packen
denn ich habe hier mantel rührteig löten
drin dann eine frucht einlage aus
heidelbeeren und drumrum habe ich eine
tonka creme und ich glaube geschmacklich
ist ja auch richtig gut ich zeige euch
jetzt aber zuerst einmal mit dem
schlittschuh geformt habe den dinkel
tierformen und dann erstmal trocknen
lassen ich werde jetzt erstmal mit dem
schlittschuh anfangen und habe jetzt
hier etwas fondant verknetet den fondant
mit zellulose pulver also mit cmc damit
ich den fondant gleich für den
schlittschuh verwenden kann und das
ganze dann auch aushärtet weil das wird
dann praktisch der körper auf die dort
das wird oben so drauf gesteckt ich habe
noch kurz überlegt ob ich 3d schumacher
aber ich glaube so auf die torte drauf
und dann so eine torte das ist krass ein
bisschen moderner und feldjäger york
besser
[Musik]
ausrollen nehme ich mir ein bisschen
becker stärke dann klebt davon dann
nicht
hier könnt ihr so theike unternehmen mit
5 mm stärke oder den aus rolf starb der
abstands ringe hat das geht auch
[Musik]
nehmt euch am besten und kater also ein
ganz scharfes messer
und schneidet dann mit hilfe der
schablone den schlittschuh aus
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und wenn ihr das dann habt könnt ihr die
details hier auch mit modell ihr
werkzeug machen wie zum beispiel mit
seinem kleinen rädchen dann habe ich
hier noch meine silikon pinsel und ich
war einfach diese ganzen linie nach
sodass der show gleich immer auch schön
[Musik]
auf jeden fall hier und die abtrennung
vom schuh zur ferse zum absatz
[Musik]
für die linie schneide ich das jetzt
hier einmal weg denn dann weiß ich genau
was ändert
[Musik]
mit diesem kleinen zahnrad mache ich
jetzt auch noch die nähte rein
ich finde es gibt immer ein schönes
detail
[Musik]
und dann zeige ich mich jetzt noch mit
lebensmittel stufen ich weiß ja immer
außen noch ganz normale filzstifte aber
sind lebensmittel stifter und damit
zeichne ich jetzt hier noch die details
auf
[Musik]
jetzt kommt es in farbe ins spiel ich
nehme hier trockene lebensmittel pulver
farben einmal metallic so dass der schuh
so ein bisschen ein paar mut glanz hat
ich glaube da wird dann auch gefallen
an der absatz mit metallic schwarz und
nämlich jetzt flüssige farbe
damit lässt sich nämlich schön
flächendeckend anmalen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
denn jetzt hier die coaching tocqueville
war
ich kann mir das
[Musik]
jetzt erst mal die farbe trocknen und
arbeiter gleich weiter denn sonst
verspüre ich gleich alles das wird schon
gleich noch schön ausgeschmückt aber so
lang kann ich schon mal die zeit nutzen
und die kuchen backen ja und da mache
ich sport jetzt heute und morgen fertig
so an zwei tagen dann kann ich mir das
gut aufteilen kuchen bieten und noch
eine frucht einlage
jetzt mache ich die frucht einlage ich
habe jetzt hier 500 gramm schwer das
sind die aus dem tiefkühlfach bei
glauben ist es nämlich so die die man im
supermarkt so in der frischetheke
bekommt es sind meister
kulturheidelbeeren und die sind nur noch
außen blau und innen weiß damit man beim
naschen einfach keine blauen finger
bekommt und die aus dem tiefkühlfach
diese ganz kleinen blaubeeren die sind
wirklich ihnen auch blau und haben
wirklich eine ganz ganz tolle farbe und
die nehme ich jetzt die habe ich auch
schon auftauen lassen und gibt da ein
bisschen donckerwolke dazu auch gar kein
zucker weil die restliche torte dann
schon süß genug wird und das ist dann so
der säuerliche bat
dann kurz pürieren
[Musik]
dann gebe es da jetzt eine tüte aka aka
dazu oder magazine und die findet ja
immer 500 milliliter flüssigkeit
[Musik]
gut durchgemischt jetzt kommt das ganze
in den topf und wird dann aufgekocht und
muss dann zwei minuten sprudelnd kochen
damit das
aggregat entfalten kann und agatha ist
ein pflanzliches geliermittel also
statine nehme ich das immer ganz gerne
manche finden da muss man halt einfach
keine gelatine benutzen und da tut's
auch wirklich das mit der pflanze und
die decke braucht es auch ein bisschen
einfacher weil ich es wirklich kochen
muss und gelatine darf man nicht kochen
und das halt immer so ein problem wenn
man das dann zu heiß in dinge rein gibt
dann wirkt sie nicht mehr und deswegen
könnt ihr hier einfach alles in einen
topf kurz aufkochen zwei minuten
sprudelnd kochen und fertig ich habe
hier noch 100 milliliter wasser dazu
gegeben beim auftauen und
kann das jetzt schön sprudelt aufkochen
lassen
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich es hier noch mal ein
messbecher zurück gefüllt damit ist
schön einfühlen kann frucht einlagen
macht jetzt am besten so entweder dem
die euch silikon formen oder nehmt euch
teller und macht der frischhaltefolie
rainer auf quatsch zu machen und ich
mache jetzt 45 frucht einlagen und die
sollten einfach vom durchmesser her
kleiner sein als die torte und was ich
auch schon zwischendurch gemacht hab ich
hab's noch nicht gewöhnt wir haben noch
ich hab noch mandelblüten gebacken 20 cm
im durchmesser und die könnt ihr einfach
backen nach meinem grundrezept auf
meinem blog denn heute wird bei uns
recht spät und wir machen dann morgen
mit der torte weiter
[Musik]
die frucht einlagen dass jetzt sie
abkühlen und friese dann ein und jetzt
komme ich jetzt auch samira was basteln
aus fondant was basteln source fondant
eine katze okay
und dann macht sie auch eine eigene
torte
[Musik]
so hast du deine katze präsentieren
das ist muffin mit schlittschuhen und
die figur lassen wir jetzt schön
trocknen und da kannst du morgen eine
ganz eigene torte machen okay ich mache
eine torte und du machst natürlich
machen gemeinsam eine wie du willst
also dass wir das trocknen bei mir
trocknet der schlittschuh und morgen
sehen wir uns wieder
ja ich habe auch schon schmidt show
gemacht ich noch kurz so
jetzt kann man die da rein setzen weil
dann kannst du dir auf die torte
draufsetzen okay jetzt
geht's ans füllen von samira scorte
alaska habe ich jetzt übrigens zum
trocknen beiseite gestellt erlag später
auch noch dazu denn sie möchte ihre
schwester eigene torte machen ich will
mal gespannt also wie gesagt gestern
habe ich dann auch die mantel rührten
mandl rührteig böden gemacht vom
grundrezept zwei stück wie zeige ich
euch gleich jetzt wird die torte gefüllt
und ich möchte torte einmal ohne fondant
machen und werde jetzt dafür eine
schweizer buttercreme machen mit eiweiß
das eiweiß wird auch pasteurisiert das
heißt es wird erwärmt und das ist wie
eine art baiser die damit butter
vermischt wird und ist echt eine leckere
creme also alle auch die sagen sie mögen
keine buttercreme wenn man die butter
lange genug rührt und wirklich das
perfekte verhältnisse schafft zwischen
eiweiß zucker und butter dann ist es
echt ein geschmackserlebnis und schmeckt
jedem ganz gut ich sage euch mal kurz
die menge dafür nehme ich 230 gramm
eiweiß einen halben teelöffel salz 400
gramm zucker tonga wanka fast 680 gramm
weiche butter 160 gramm puderzucker und
hier habe ich jetzt noch ein gekochter
heidelberg das waren auch die aus dem
tiefkühlfach und ich hab die so lange
einkochen lassen bis wirklich fast keine
flüssigkeit mit da ist und dass jetzt
eine richtig schöne dickflüssige masse
damit werde ich später die creme auch
färben und dann gucke ich mal vielleicht
komme ich sogar ganz ohne farb- passten
aus mal schauen wichtig ist jetzt dass
das eiweiß mit salz und zucker verrührt
wird und entweder macht ihr das dann auf
dem herd über einen kochenden wasser bat
und dann wirklich für zehn minuten mit
dem handrührgerät oder ihr nehmt eure
kennwort wenn ihr eine habt und macht
das ganze bei 70 grad für zehn minuten
immer schön rühe und so wird das eiweiß
schon fest und eben pasteurisiert dann
kann da auch nichts mehr passieren und
es wird vor allem sehr stabil und später
die buttercreme schön cremig
[Musik]
und wenn ihr jetzt nicht so viel eiweiß
nehmen wollt könnt ihr auch die
französische buttercreme machen da wird
nämlich eiweiß und eigelb verwendet aber
dann wird die creme auch ein bisschen
gelblich und ich möchte jetzt ein
relativ weiß haben deswegen nur die und
das könnt ihr auch ganz gut einfrieren
oder ihr könnt eine eigene presste
verwaltung machen oder ein raise daraus
zubereiten
da könnt ihr einfach andere schöne dinge
damit tun sagt es wird jetzt immer schön
verrührt
[Musik]
nachdem zehn minuten schalte ich einfach
die temperatur aus neben auch den deckel
herunter und kann die creme jetzt
einfach schön wieder kalt rühren also so
lange rühren bis sie einfach wieder
schönen raumtemperatur angenommen hat
[Musik]
und dass praktisch auch der moment bei
dem er das eiweiß vom wasserbad herr
unternimmt und einfach hier im hunsrück
gerät weiter rührt und wichtig ist es
sollte wirklich mit der raumtemperatur
annehmen damit die butter später nicht
schmilzt und sobald es ganz abgekühlt
ist und durch gerührt ist werde ich die
butter mit dem puderzucker vermischen
und in der küchenmaschine separat schön
aufregend stars ungefähr zehn minuten
bis die buttercreme schön weiß cremig
ist
[Musik]
auch hier sieht nach viel butter aus es
ist auch viel butter aber es wird auch
eine große torte das verspielt sich
tom kha schmeckt hier sehr gut
dann las ich nicht aufhören
und wenn die mutter jetzt richtig schön
weiß cremig ist wird beides von boni ihr
lastete weiter rühren und gibt dann
immer ein bisschen was von der eiweiß
maße dazu
[Musik]
[Applaus]
super dann ist die butter themen fertig
wo meine frucht einlagen und die
tortenböden und dann wird die torte
gefüllt ich habe ich jetzt meine beiden
böden 20 zentimeter im durchmesser und
ich habe jetzt hier mein grundrezept
gemacht mantel rührteig böden und habe
das ganze aber auch fünf eier
hochgerechnet damit ich einfach relativ
hohe böden habt und die torte auch schön
hoch wird also da könnt ihr gerne
einfach in der app oder auf meinem blog
vorbei schauen bei den grund rezepten
aber natürlich gebe ich die menge auch
ganz explizit in diesem rezept an nur
die zubereitung das muss jetzt nicht
mehr zeigen da schau dir einfach im
grundrezept video vorbei
und das backpapier was ich hier
verwendet habt das bewahre ich jetzt
noch auf brauche ich später eventuell
noch für die dekoration also nicht
wegschmeißen genau und die habe ich
jetzt gestern schon gebacken damit sie
schön durch kühlen und dann habe ich
sehr abgedeckt im kühlschrank stehen
lassen so lassen sie sich besser
durchschneiden also jetzt sehen sie ein
bisschen bröselig aus weil ich den rand
abgelöst habe aber gleich beim schneiden
sind die mich bröselig das dann immer
noch beim herauslösen
und dann nehme ich jetzt tue tortenböden
und schneit jetzt jeweils drei böden zu
und dann habe ich sechs stück insgesamt
und dann ist es eine torte die einfach
vom verhältnis herr boden frucht füllung
creme hat und dann ist es immer richtig
schön wenn die böden nicht so dick sind
[Musik]
wenn ihr beim backen darauf achtet dass
der tortenring nicht ganz 20 cm hat
sondern ein bisschen weniger 5 mm
weniger dann könnt ihr jetzt gleich
diese garching boards benutzen denn
damit lassen sich torten perfekt glatt
streichen ich zeige euch auch gleich wie
wichtig ist einfach wirklich dass hier
der kuchen so ein bisschen spielraum
noch nach außen also 5 mm reichen auf
jeden fall da kommt jetzt der erste
tortenboden drauf dann etwas creme
schön verteilen
und ich fühle die torte ohne tortenring
drumherum aber wenn ihr beim torte
befüllen nicht so ganz geübt seid könnt
ihr gerne ein tortenring darum stellen
gern auch mit einer folie mit seiner
torten rand folie dann lässt sich das
später auch einfach wieder raus lösen
wichtig ist jetzt nämlich hier einfach
die torte schön glatt zu füllen also
kein hobel bilden
so ein bisschen buttercreme
dann kommt die gefrorene frucht einlage
direkt drauf
und die sollen auch gefroren sein
damit man sie eben schön aus der hand
drauf setzen kann ohne dass sie kaputt
gehen jetzt buttercreme wieder drauf zum
abdecken und jetzt müsst ihr bald stehen
hubl von der frucht einlage kaschieren
und die creme drumherum glattstreichen
die flacher die frucht einlage ist umso
flacher unsere umso weniger produkte
braucht ihr aber umso weniger hoch wird
dann auch die torte also das könnte
jetzt individuell bestimmen
und wenn ihr merkt die torte ist nicht
kalt genug dann stellt sie immer
zwischendurch kurz kalt und füllt sie
dann weiter
kugel ist kugel ein hochdeutsches orte 3
wird isaac opel was hat stets auch gott
ich jetzt der tortenboden ist zerstört
bist mache ich so was dieser nehme ich
meine meinten retter
afelley
vor lauter gruppe
am besten denn die tortenböden immer mit
einem torten retter
legt sie dann flach drauf das kriegen
wir hin
fuchs
habe ich den ernsthaft mit einer hand
einfach als wäre es so im buch und
[Musik]
so füllt er jetzt einfach die gesamte
torte
[Musik]
jetzt vorletzte frucht einlage als ich
empfehle euch wirklich flachere flucht
anlagen zu machen denn ich brauche
gerade extrem viel butter grillen zum
film ich dachte eigentlich dass die im
keller zu groß sind aber die hätten
genau gepasst weil da ist der boden
unten relativ klein und dann hätte ich
ganz kleine dünne frucht einlagen machen
können ihnen den kleinen immer egal beim
nächsten mal ich finde die hat auch mit
so einem google schön aber der jubel ist
relativ hoch und kleinem durchmesser bin
froh dass ich nicht die suppen schale
genommen hat
war so ein kurve herum kommen so fünf
zentimeter butter kleben
werden so eine firma korte der marke
lebt buttercreme ok und als obersten
boden oder deckel bzw nehme ich immer
den buntesten boden ja dann ist die
torte schön glatt
also noch nett glatt aber gleich klasse
und das zweite gage dort raucht dann
kann man es immer auch schön platt
drücken und ich nehme jetzt erstmal eine
tankkarte
in den hier alles am rand mit der teig
karte kann man es nicht immer so schön
rein drücken
und bevor ich aber jetzt die torte glatt
bekommen ihr seht auch schon die ist
jetzt noch relativ instabil
muss die erst mal in den kühlschrank
damit die füllung schön fest wird die
buttercreme fest wird die torte erstmal
an stabilität gewinnt und wenn ihr
möchtet könnt ihr jetzt gerne auch
drumherum torten rand folie legen und
einen tortenring dann ist sie einfach
schön kompakt eingepackt ich glaube es
mache ich sogar gleich stellen sie dann
für eine stunde in den kühlschrank und
die übrige buttercreme die last bei
raumtemperatur stehen sofern es bei euch
zu hause nicht so warm ist also wenn ihr
merkt mit zu warmen packt diese am
besten in kühlen ort aber nicht in den
kühlschrank ihr könnt sie auch in den
kühlschrank stellen müsst ihr aber
später noch einmal aufschlagen weil sie
dann halt echt viel zu kalt und zu fest
wird genau
seit zum nutzen zumal dort die ruhe bis
elo gleichkommt und werde die torte
glatt streichen wie gesagt gefühlt ist
sie jetzt schon
guckt mal wie schön
und die folie die kann ich auch immer
wieder verwenden
die werde ich gleich abwaschen und
jetzt nehme ich meine buttercreme und
werde jetzt erst einmal die ganzen
löcher hieraus stoppt die hier
entstanden sind und da habe ich auch
immer so ein zweites schälchen denn da
dürfen ja dann krümel rein und dann ist
das ganz okay und die rest buttercreme
die muss natürlich schön sauber bleiben
ich musste jetzt weil ich wie gesagt zu
hohe funkt anlagen macht hat nochmal
buttercreme zubereiten aber die menge
reicht auf jeden fall zur torte wenn ihr
den bisschen flacher macht sie einfach
schön rein spachteln
[Musik]
da ein bisschen creme obendrauf
aber da muss jetzt nicht so viel
heller zeichnet gerade ihre torte auf
die tafel auf
ich habe ein bisschen angst das ist
heute eskaliert noch dass sie zu viel
machen will
jetzt gebe ich ihr das zweite garagen
bord drauf und es hat die gleiche größe
wie unten und jetzt achtet ihr einfach
nur drauf dass es hier im rechten winkel
ist
praktisch die lücke hier und da für die
jetzt alles mit der creme auf und dann
habt ihr so eine torte wirklich im
handumdrehen schönen glatt gestrichen
dann schön knapp abziehen
[Musik]
jetzt können sie hier oben das caching
bord unternehmen ganz vorsichtig
mit einem messer oder mit einer palette
ganz vorsichtig da runter gehen
und dann praktisch hier oben noch kurz
glatt streichen und auffüllen und dann
kann es schon dran gehen oder kann ich
schon dran gehen und die buttercreme
einfärben und die torte dekorieren ich
habe ich so ein bisschen zeitdruck sei
es nämlich schon in den startlöchern und
ich weiß wenn sie in die küche kommt
dann muss ich mein zepter ablegen
aber ich glaube ich lese jetzt gleich
dazu da kann man so parallel arbeiten
einmal so und
hier oben einmal von außen nach innen
und dann ist die torte platz
bevor ich sie kalt stellen sehe ich sie
noch kurz von der garagen platte runter
denn die möchte ich später nicht mehr
unter der trave haben
[Musik]
ich habe ich jetzt das ein gekochter
heidelberg püree oder noch blaue
lebensmittel verpasste ich mache das ist
nämlich so ich habe jetzt erst mal eine
kleine menge ein und
bei passend farben ist es so wenn die
ware gemacht werden dann intensiviert
sich die farbe also das kennt ihr
vielleicht auch vom bakken her so dass
dann nach dem backen der teig einfach
schön dunkel ist und vor dem backen
waren noch nicht so und deswegen rät er
das jetzt erstmal hier ein
deshalb ist so ein schönes zartes blau
und stellt diese kleine menge
buttercreme aber kurz in die mikrowelle
und dann wird es gleich dunkler
und die zweite creme färbe ich jetzt
hier mit
mit der heidelberg passte
es gab so ein blau lila das gefällt ihr
ganz gut da samira und
jetzt auch ein bisschen blau mit dazu
und dann haben wir gleich einen schönen
richtig tollen tatverlauf
einfach nur so ein paar sekunden dann
reicht das schon guckt mal ist das schön
dunkel
[Musik]
da steht jetzt vorher aufgezeichneten
sehr gut
wir können eiskristalle bei dir machen
ob sie so malt
okay guck ich habe auch dass so ein trip
dann könnte auch die torte mit seinem
trip darunter fließt
das ist mitmachen das fließt dann am
rand runter wenn du wünschst ort daran
kann es runter fließen
maximal probieren
konnten die ägyptisch dann seine klasse
das zu topf dann im rahmen zur und das
spiel weiße schokolade konkurrieren
thomas späth das runter laufen lassen
okay super dann gebe ich dir jetzt
gleich creme zum aufstreichen der topf
für die torte
maschinen die torte bleibt ist blau beim
machen
magst du keine blaubeeren habe ich mag
sie ok ich
stelle halten
ella ist okay wenn ich meine torte so
lang weiter ja
ja die gebe ich das sofort ich muss kurz
meine einstreiche und dann gebe ich dir
die übrige crémant
blaue creme das ist ja okay
ich brauch weißt wie du okay ich gebe
dir weiß ich habe hier ganz viel weiß
okay und ich werde jetzt hier auf nur
eine torte eine ja wieso eine marmor
ihre optik machen von einem spachtel
optik was ich geb dir das gleich oh mein
gott jetzt wird jetzt ab jetzt wird es
heiss mit ella und habe jetzt hier eben
dieses blau dann so ein bisschen rot und
lila und streiche jetzt praktisch die
creme mit einer palette hier außen an
sich macht ihr so farbtupfer drauf
ja die habe ich noch auf dem schrank
damit doch keiner ran geht und so ein
bisschen was von diesem lila aber nicht
so viel
ein bisschen was davon
unten so ein bisschen dunkler als oben
und jetzt bin ich mal gespannt ob das so
funktioniert
ich glaube zwar nicht
jetzt mit datei karte
entlangziehen
und dann sieht es aus wie seine
spachteltechnik
und dann kann man das noch mal machen
ok ich glaube meine kranke
und ich mache noch mal ein bisschen was
drauf
und dann vermischt sich das schön
[Musik]
der ist auch vor groß wie der
gleiche das nur noch nicht gefüllt
ich stelle die torte kurz im kühlschrank
helfer mit ihrer torte und dann machen
wir gleich noch aus reispapier ganz
tolle dekorationen okay dass man nicht
so hoch weil das geht das bei mir auch
schon schiefgegangen
machte kurz ich helf dir und euch jetzt
hier eigentlich nur einfach die
buttercreme rein oder wünsch dir
vielleicht mit schokolade
dann schmilzt sich jetzt ein bisschen
schokolade oder kommt es da rein nein
nicht da rein machen
[Musik]
kathrein ufs
sagen du bist die torten künstlerin
vaters gelingt ist
das brauche ich noch versucht
mir willst denn ein crêpe da war sagte
mir mal rosa okay daneben steht einfach
die blaubeeren des wird an rosa rugosa
das wird
[Musik]
dann mach doch mal das und ich zeige
euch jetzt noch wie wir aus reispapier
für dekorationen machen wir können
nämlich zaubern aber jetzt gleich
wir machen jetzt schöne dekorationen aus
reispapier reispapier bekommt ihr in
asiatischen läden oder in gut sortierten
supermärkten auch in der asien abteilung
ist einfach ganz dünnes papier woraus
man zb sammer es macht und die schmecken
ganz neutrale reibungsfrei
frühlingsrollen sind nicht aus
reispapier aber sommer rollen und dann
brauche ich noch metallic pulver farbe
und am besten noch eine verpasste ich
nehme jetzt blau weil das ganze bei uns
ein bisschen blau lila wird und ich habe
ich jetzt eine schale mit wasser das
wasser sollte warm sein und ich mache es
jetzt hier einfach im mai teller weil
ich den herd anschalten kann und das
wasser einfach schön warm bleibt
ansonsten kühls immer zu schnell ab und
dann müsstet ihr immer wieder frisches
wasser nehmen so und jetzt nehme ich
hier verpasste rein
das habt ihr hier so ein farbverlauf
und wenn ihr möchtet ihr noch mit alec
dazu geben so ein bisschen stimmung
dieses kreisblatt eintauchen und einfach
kurz pflegen lassen
ist es schön weich wird da könnt ihr
euch auf papier das er das was ich
vorhin hat mich übrig hatte so kleine
dreidimensionale nestchen bauunternehmen
der bug folie und zumba klammern oder
backpapier und das zerknüllt ihr einfach
dann könnte das hier raus nehmen sich so
ein bisschen aus wie so ein gelatine
blatt aber es ist nur reis und jetzt
hier so drauf legen und dann seht ihr
auch schon das je nach dem wie es hier
liegt so eben die vom auch festwirt und
was ihr da noch machen könnt ihr könnt
noch mal ein bisschen verpasste nehmen
und so ein bisschen schattierungen auch
reinmachen an so manche stellen gerne
auch ein bisschen lila also die farbe
die ihr gerne haben wollte und das mache
ich jetzt so und dann lass es entweder
bei luft trocknen also hier raus und es
dauert ein bisschen länger oder in den
winter automaten oder die restwärme des
backofens es muss einfach wieder die
feuchtigkeit weg ich mache jetzt gleich
in der automaten aber ansonsten könnt
ihr so was auch gut vorbereiten so ein
paar tage vorher und einfach bei
raumtemperatur liegen lassen das geht
auch ganz gut jetzt
richtig
was für pancake
ich hätte mal butter zucker
[Musik]
mama fink entstehen hier sitzt doch die
sanitäter java stehen geht schwierig
beide torten und
dessen
[Musik]
ich habe beim ablegen immer schön fertig
ablegen wollte das macht dann richtig
schönen effekt und dann könnt ihr
einfach immer wieder den nächsten
reichstag blätter nehmen ins wasser
drücken
warten bis sie einreichen und damit zum
trocknen raus legen ich mache mir noch
was sagen sie ihren geburtstag
sondern konnten auch gehabt dann stelle
ich die torte bisschen weiter weg von
dir gästen
da müssen wir vorsichtig sein mit
fontänen
ein stück zurück
aha
praxis an ihre single
und was die torte wunder wunder
wunderschön gebacken vielen dank
und jetzt dieser mirage gt
silber regen fontäne vor was für tolle
sterne sind
schöne von plänen und so lang wie die
brend hoffe ich dass der rauch mit der
drittliga hinten trägt wow
wow
der schlittschuh ist auch gut
durchgetrocknet und da fehlen jetzt
natürlich noch diese schnürsenkel die
mache ich jetzt einfach aus gefärbtem
fondant so kleine röllchen und die könnt
ihr dann schön dran kleben
mit essbarem kleber
[Musik]
jetzt kann man das finale die tore wird
zusammengewirkt also das schloss fertig
buttercreme habe ich hier noch in
kleinen spritzbeutel damit die tupfen
oben drauf machen kann ich will dass
eine recht moderne torte wird also werde
ich gucken dass ich nicht komplett alles
bedeckt sondern eher so im hinteren
bereich und nehmt dann noch kate opfer
aus holz und weil ihr die holzoptik
nicht so gut passt werde ich jetzt hier
das ganze noch einmal mit
lebensmittelfarben ich bin jetzt aber
überlegen ob ich ihn erst für samir
annehmen rp
wurde alles gut aber ich glaube ich
nehmen es für samira
ich wollte eigentlich ne 11 ich habe nur
noch eine 1
das mal ich gold an
oder passt separate mal zum schuh
das mache ich zum schloss dass man mal
ein paar tropfen
[Musik]
eine kleine planänderung die kurve des
schlittschuhs wird gold und dann mache
ich goldene herzen kommen
die frauen sekunde
[Musik]
und stieß er reispapier deko dieses auch
schon getrocknet und wenn ihr wollt
könnt ihr hier am rand auf immer gerne
mal mit metallic farben noch was so
anmalen und
steht dann im prinzip einfach in die
torte einstecken oder an den rand kleben
[Musik]
okay heute wenig riskant ich froh wir
jetzt noch ein bisschen metallic farben
darauf zu sprengen
[Musik]
habe ich jetzt doch noch dazu
entschlossen die
holzfigur den holz buchstaben noch an zu
malen ich nehme es auch noch mit dazu
und jetzt habe ich hier den schlittschuh
den fertigen und einen ice stil auf holz
und habe jetzt isomalt geschmolzen und
das ist ein zucker der aber nicht so
schnell karamellisiert wie ganz normaler
zucker ihr könnt auch bonbons nehmen zum
beispiel eines bonbons und die
einschmelzen denn damit kann man das
jetzt perfekt kleben aber vorsicht es
echt sehr heiß und
es auch schön durchsichtig und vor allem
trockenes gleich
einfach hier dran
so könnt ihr zum beispiel
lebkuchenhäuschen auch am besten kleben
statt zuckerguss einfach weil es einfach
innerhalb von sekunden fest wird und
dann muss man eben nicht warten bis das
trocknet glaubt so fest habe ich das
noch ganz kurz liegen bis es fertig
trocknet und was ich jetzt hier an der
torte noch machen werde also ich finde
es jetzt echt schön auch mit der
metallic farbe hier drumherum ich denke
mir gefällt das vor allem auch sehr gut
weil es hier auch so eine kleine
künstler kann ist eine große künstlerin
klein war übertrieben eher untertrieben
untertrieben sein wer malt jetzt schon
besser als alle anderen hier und ich
nehme jetzt hier noch diese top box und
die metallic flex die passen farblich
echt gut dazu denn mir hat so ein
bisschen noch was zum streuen gefehlt
und die strecke ist auch noch drauf
die sind vor allem nicht nur schön
sondern auch lecker weil es eben
schokolade ist und nicht einfach nur
puderzucker und dann beißt man da nicht
auch so was hat ist sondern es ist
einfach eine schöne schokolade
[Musik]
und mit der
so
ich konnte überlegen wohin
[Musik]
quartiers die torte fertig das rezept
findet ihr in meiner app und auch auf
meinem blog und jetzt bin ich schon
ziemlich gespannt darauf wie samira die
tore gefallen wird ich mache auf jeden
fall aufnahmen mit dem handy wenn ihre
freunde da sind und wenn sie morgens
überrascht wird das machen wir immer zum
ritual das abends wenn das
geburtstagskind im bett legt dekorieren
wer komplett das wohnzimmer und tun halt
immer so als wären sven hat und dann
kommt sie morgens runter und bekommt
ihre überraschung ja ich bin mal
gespannt ob das bei ihr noch zeit aber
ich glaube schon mal überraschen lässt
sie sich gerne also probiert gerne aus
ich hoffe euch gefällt auch diese neue
technik die hatte ich einfach online mal
gesehen wollte ausprobieren und falls
ihr torten wünsche habt oder anregungen
oder ihr sagt buck doch mal eine torte
mit diesem unter jedem thema dann
schreibt mir ganz gerne ihr wisst ich
bin immer sehr mädchen lustig weil ich
halt zwei mädels habt ganz klar aber
wenn ihr mir auch sagt auch was eure
jungs stehen gerade so bei torten und
was sie gerne schauen dann schreibt es
mir einfach weil da bin ich mit so einem
thema drin weil ich halt keine jungs und
mädels deswegen bleibt gesund bis bald
das nächste mal ist
immer komisch so ein video abschluss
ohne probieren aber ihr habt mit
geburtstagstorten werden hat nicht
probiert die kriegt das geburtstagskind
und deswegen kommt die im kühlschrank
aber sie noch vergessen habe das
reispapier werde ich jetzt gleich
nochmal unternehmen deren das reispapier
würde jetzt sonst die feuchtigkeit
aufnehmen und dann wird's wieder weich
also das stecke ich dann einfach kurz
vor verzehr wieder drauf so ein zwei
stunden kann schon halten aber alles
andere wird zur feucht werden
habt ihr wir können es doch ein problem
machen denn ich ein stück torte übrig
des videos nach dem geburtstag
nach dem geburtstag also branche er war
vor drei tagen nicht
einstellen will drei tage später darf
ich den kuchen ist diese hat er aus der
ich habe er beim geburtstag hatte ich
keine zeit dem tod zu probieren weil
einfach zu viele kinder in einem raum
war
die band ist natürlich
das war richtig schön also wenn jetzt
sommer über sarahs geburtstag reden darf
er hat neun kinder eingeladen
und das war auch echt zunächst mal die
sind also zwischen zehn und elf jahren
alt ja da haben uns hier in der küche
getroffen dann haben die pässe gespielt
und alles und dann hatte ich schieß
tactics vorbereitet also käse kuchen
gebacken am stiel eingefroren und habe
dann einmal eine große portion kuvertüre
temperiert und hab das dann mit denen
echt schön dekorierte sind die dürften
dann die cheesecake sticks ich habe nie
gedopt und ich habe hier toppings
ausgebreitet und die hat einen echten
schönen nachmittag und ich auch das war
echt entspannend und schön mit den kids
dem toll mitgemacht war echt der hammer
aber ich verstehe ein ich habe immer
gedacht was sind das für eltern
die ihre kinder
geburtstag im mcdonald's feiern lassen
oder hast du mal kinder oder hast du
auch eine geburtstagsparty oder weiß
schon ganz genau warum dies gemacht habt
ihr noch wenig ganz tolle idee es geht
gar nicht darum dass es mit tolles essen
nicht gut ist es geht einfach nur darum
die arbeit die arbeiten zu hause ich
verstehe so als seien wir waren dann
auch schon als andere zeiten wand gleich
man jetzt habe ich da kommen wir bleiben
lieber daheim
was wünscht dann auch groß irgendwo
unternehmen und wir waren auch schon in
so einem klappte land oder in so einem
indoor-spielplatz das ist auch schon
immer ganz cool weil man muss auch dazu
sagen viele eltern sind berufstätig und
dann könnt ihr das auto heim auch kann
immer haben weil ich so viele kinder
aber wenn man was kreatives macht und
die kids beschäftigt dann kommt erst gar
keine langeweile auf dann entsteht kein
quatsch dann steht es war echt ein
richtig schöner tag wurde bringt dem ex
kinder und da können sie gut abreißen
ich sehe das öfters mal ich will das
nicht in die länge ziehen aber man sieht
es öfters mal dass sich eltern und so
extrem viel mühe gegeben also voll
dekorieren und dann während instagram
fotos gemacht ist wird so zelebriert
oder sich mal vor nicht mal meine
hochzeit war so schön versteht was ich
meine wie der kindergeburtstag meines
kindes und so dekoriert auswaschen der
abete macht euch diesen stress nicht ich
dachte kinder damit sehr sehr wenig
zufrieden
wir brauchen die instagram genau ich
hatte zum beispiel keine kinder ich
musste gleich arbeiten deswegen ja ja
wir wollen hier keinen tropfen gerade
die torte also ich fand die gestern noch
besser weil ich sie gestern habe draußen
bisschen stehen lassen also
buttercremetorte solltet ihr darauf
achten dass ihr die nicht sofort aus dem
kühlschrank ist weil dann schmeckt die
botschaft ein bisschen wie ein ja ist
auch cool aber so ein bisschen
raumtemperatur annehmen lassen und dann
schmeckt das echte hammer die kids war
begann schon also die haben alle gar
nicht so ein ganzes stück geschafft aber
ich hab' ich muss das dünne scheiben
geschnitten und dann halbiert und dann
war es perfekt der brasilianer und drei
tage später immer noch gut zwei tage
später also noch besser und ich glaube
jetzt kann auch morgen noch essen sozial
und da kannst du dich auf die
raumtemperaturen butter kriegen ganz
ganz wichtig raumtemperatur
und ihr könnt ihr gerne noch schreiben
welche torten kombination weil ich finde
ich aber jetzt hier diese heidel bei
einlagen die blaubeeren und diese tonka
creme und ich finde kombi der hammer mit
dem angeboten ihr könnt ja gerne
schreiben was du eure lieblings torten
kommen wir mal kombi war schokolade
früchte waren einfach schreiben jedoch
oder schreibt
ja dann weiß ich dass wir drauf sein
macht macht besser
[Musik]